♪
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CLASS OF
2022!
[ APPLAUSE ]
EARLIER THIS SEMESTER,
I WENT TO GRAB A CUP OF
COFFEE IN A DINING HALL.
IT WAS A SUNNY DAY AND
EARLY IN THE MORNING.
AND THE WORLD FELT QUIET.
I DECIDED TO TAKE THE LONG WAY
HOME, LINGERING IN THE SILENCE
OF CAMPUS FOR A FEW EXTRA
MOMENTS.
I WALKED AN I THOUGHT ABOUT ALL
THE PEOPLE STILL ASLEEP WHO
SURROUNDED ME.
WARM IN THEIR
BEDS, NOT YET CONSCIOUS
OF THE DAY.
ON ROSE WALK, A WOMAN
WHEELING A CART OF PAPERS
WALKED SWIFTLY BY, PHONE IN
HAND. I OVERHEAD A SNIPPET OF
CONVERSATION SHE WAS HAVING
IN FRENCH.
AT ELM, SHE TURNED
RIGHT AND DISAPPEARED.
I STOPPED AND THOUGHT
ABOUT HER. WE HAD JUST
SHARED A MOMENT, THOUGH
PERHAPS SHE WAS UNAWARE OF IT.
AND I WAS STRUCK BY HOW MUCH I
COULD GUESS ABOUT HER LIFE.
THAT
SHE WAS PROBABLY CALLING
SOMEONE
SHE CARED ABOUT VERY MUCH. THAT
SHE LIKELY HAD EXPERIENCED
HOMESICKNESS, AS ALL PEOPLE
DO WHO LIVE FAR FROM HOME.
THAT IT TOOK PLANNING AND CARE
TO CALL SOMEONE WHO WAS ENDING
THEIR DAY AS SHE BEGAN HERS.
THAT IT WASN'T ALWAYS EASY.
I REALIZED WE HAD A LOT IN
COMMON DESPITE NOT KNOWING
HER AND HER NOT KNOWING ME.
I'VE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN COLLEGE MISSING
PHONE CALLS FROM FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. WHEN IT'S MORNING HERE,
EVERYONE I LOVE BACK HOME
IS ASLEEP. LIKE THIS WOMAN,
I'VE EXPERIENCED HOMESICKNESS.
I'VE LEARNED HOW MUCH EFFORT
IT TAKES TO MAINTAIN
RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE
WHO LIVE FAR AWAY━AND ALSO,
THAT THIS EFFORT IS WORTH IT.
AT YALE, WE ARE CONNECTED TO
A CERTAIN EXTENT BY VIRTUE OF
BEING AT THIS SCHOOL.
IF YOU ARE PRE-MED,
I KNOW YOU PROBABLY
HAD A HARD SEMESTER IN ORGO.
PERHAPS YOUR HARD SEMESTER
IN ORGO COINCIDED WITH
MY HARD SEMESTER IN AMERICAN
LIT. PERHAPS WE CRIED
AT THE SAME TIME IN THE
SAME LIBRARY.
ME ONE FLOOR ABOVE.
WE ARE CONNECTED
BECAUSE WE CAN GUESS
JUST ENOUGH ABOUT EACH
OTHER'S LIVES -
BECAUSE WE SHARE YALE.
BUT THE SAME STILL HOLD
TRUE WITHOUT NEEDING
TO SHARE YALE.
IN FACT, WHAT
I HAD IN COMMON WITH
THE WOMAN ON ROSE WALK
HAD LITTLE TO DO WITH
YALE. IT HAD MUCH MORE
TO DO WITH CHOOSING
TO NOTICE WHAT CONNECTED US.
MANY OF US ARE ABOUT
TO ENTER A WORLD OF
STRANGERS, A WORLD OF
UNFAMILIAR PEOPLE, FACES
AND NAMES. AND WE HATE
WE'RE TERRIFIED OF THIS.
WE HAVE AN IDEA
THAT YALE IS THE
END OF ALL POSSIBILITY
FOR HUMAN CONNECTION,
THE END OF FRIENDSHIP.
AN IDEA THAT IS DISTINCTLY
ANTI-STRANGER AND AN
IDEA THAT DOES NOTHING
FOR US BUT CLOSE US
OFF FROM THE WORLD.
BUT YALE HAS PREPARED
US FOR LIFE BEYOND
COLLEGE BY EQUIPPING
US WITH ONE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT SKILL:
PERCEPTION.
WHILE WE USE THIS SKILL
ALL THE TIME IN OUR
LEARNING, WE ALSO USE
IT EVERY TIME WE MEET A NEW
PERSON. WE HAVE LEARNED TO
CONNECT WITH PEOPLE FROM ALL
KINDS OF BACKGROUNDS.
ALL KINDS OF PLACES.
AND THOUGH WE MAY TELL
OURSELVES THAT WE ARE
FRIENDS BECAUSE WE
SHARE YALE, THE TRUTH
IS THAT WHILE YALE MAY
HAVE BROUGHT US TOGETHER,
THIS SCHOOL HAS NEVER BEEN
THE REASON FOR OUR
CONNECTION.
YALE HAS GIVEN YOU
A PERCEPTIVE EYE.
USE IT WITH INTENTION.
NOTICE THE GIRL WEARING A
T-SHIRT WITH YOUR FAVORITE
BAND ON IT, LISTEN TO THE
LANGUAGES AND ACCENTS THAT
SURROUND YOU, PEER OVER THE
SHOULDER OF THE PERSON
SITTING NEXT TO YOU ON THE
SUBWAY. MAYBE THEY'RE READING
YOUR FAVORITE BOOK,
GETTING LOST IN SOMETHING
THAT BROUGHT YOU JOY BACK
WHEN YOU WERE SITTING IN A
CLASSROOM IN LC.
AND ON THE DAYS WHEN
YOU DON'T WANT TO
BE PERCEPTIVE, THAT'S
OKAY TOO. PICK UP THE
PHONE AND CALL THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SITTING NEXT TO YOU
TODAY. REMEMBER THAT
CONNECTION EXISTS
IN MANY FORMS,
IN MANY MOMENTS.
THROUGH BEING PERCEPTIVE,
YOU WILL DISCOVER
FRIENDSHIP, EMPATHY, AND
COMMUNITY. IN OTHER WORDS,
YOU WILL BRING THE FEELING
OF YALE WITH YOU INTO
ALL OF THE SPACES YOU INHABIT.
CONGRATULATIONS,
CLASS OF 2022,
AND GOOD LUCK OUT THERE.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HELLO!
HELLO HELLO.
ASSALAMUALAIKUM,
AND WELCOME FRIENDS,
FAMILY, LOVED ONES,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
THE YALE CLASS OF 2022,
TO CLASS DAY!
[  CHEERS ]
MY NAME IS YOUSRA OMER,
AND I AM ONE OF THE FIVE
MEMBERS OF THE
CLASS DAY COMMITTEE.
AS A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE,
I HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH YALE FACULTY,
STAFF, AND FELLOW STUDENTS
TO BRING YOU THIS CELEBRATION
TO COMMEMORATE OUR COLLECTIVE
YALE EXPERIENCE.
AS A CLASS.
[  CHEERS ]
JAY: ESTONKO FULLACKVT, JAY
FIFE
CVHOCEFKVT OS. ESTE MVSKOKE
TOWIS!
GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS JAY FIFE AND I AM
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE YALE
CLASS OF 2022 CLASS DAY
COMMITTEE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CLASS DAY EMERGED IN THE
19TH CENTURY AS YALIES
GATHERED HERE ON OLD CAMPUS
TO RECOUNT, SHARE, AND CREATE
MEMORIES.
ON THIS BEAUTIFUL DAY,
WE WILL CELEBRATE THE
HISTORIC YALE CLASS OF 2022
WITH REFLECTIONS;
WITNESS MEMBERS OF OUR CLASS
RECEIVE PRIZES FOR ACADEMIC,
ARTISTIC AND ATHLETIC
ACHIEVEMENTS AND
PRACTICE LONG-STANDING
CLASS DAY TRADITIONS.
LATER IN THE CEREMONY,
OUR THREE FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL SHARE MORE DETAILS
ABOUT THOSE TRADITIONS.
BUT FIRST UP IS THE
CLASS DAY ADDRESS,
DELIVERED EACH YEAR
BY A NOTABLE SPEAKER.
YOUSRA: RETURNING TO YALE
FOR OUR KEYNOTE ADDRESS,
RESHMA SAUJANI COMES TO
SHARE HER JOURNEY AND THE
WISDOM COLLECTED ALONG
THE WAY WITH THE
CLASS OF 2022,
BUT SHE ALSO COMES
TO BE INSPIRED BY THE
RESILIENCE, BRAVERY, AND
DETERMINATION OF OUR
GRADUATING CLASS.
MS. SAUJANI'S
LIFE IS DRIVEN BY
INSPIRATION AS A
FIRST-GENERATION
IMMIGRANT COMING
FROM A FAMILY OF
INDIAN REFUGEES TO UGANDA.
SHE GREW UP IN ILLINOIS
AND ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY
OF ILLINOIS, EARNING HER
BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN OUR SHARED FIELD
OF POLITICAL SCIENCE.
AS WITH ANY OF OUR
JOURNEYS, ALL ROADS LEAD BACK
TO YALE.
BUT MS. SAUJANI
DECIDED TO TAKE A TRIP TO A
LESSER-KNOWN INSTITUTION,
THE HARVARD KENNEDY SCHOOL
OF GOVERNMENT FOR
-- OSHOOT.
NO ONE IS FAMILIAR WITH THAT
ONE.
SHE WENT THERE TO EARN HER
MASTER'S
POLICY.
SHE THEN ARRIVED AT THE
GOLDEN GATES OF THE YALE LAW
SCHOOL, WHERE SHE RECEIVED
HER JURIS DOCTORATE IN 2002.
MS. SAUJANI HAS HAD AN
ILLUSTRIOUS CAREER
FROM HER WORK
AS AN ATTORNEY,
POLITICAL ORGANIZER,
CAMPAIGNING FOR A SEAT IN THE
U.S HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES,
SERVING AS THE NEW YORK CITY
DEPUTY PUBLIC ADVOCATE,
AND FOUNDING GIRLS WHO CODE,
A NONPROFIT STRIVING TO
CLOSE THE GENDER GAP
BY TEACHING GIRLS AND
YOUNG WOMEN COMPUTING
SKILLS, SO THEY CAN BE
MORE COMPETITIVE
WITHIN THE
TECHNOLOGY SECTOR.
MS. SAUJANI HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED AMONG
FORTUNE WORLD'S “GREATEST
LEADERS,”
FORTUNE'S “40 UNDER 40”
LIST, AND AS ONE OF
FORBES'S “MOST POWERFUL
WOMEN CHANGING THE WORLD,”
AMONG MANY OTHERS.
BUT PERHAPS SOME
OF HER GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS COME
IN THE FORM OF HER
FAMILY WITH HER HUSBAND
NIHAL AND THEIR SONS
SHAAN AND SAI.
HER CAREER SPEAKS
FOR ITSELF AND
EMBODIES SEVERAL
OF THE FIELDS THAT
MANY OF US WILL BE
ENTERING IN THE
NOT-SO-DISTANT FUTURE.
THE ONLY WAY TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW SHE HAS
DONE IT ALL IS TO
HEAR FROM MS. SAUJANI
HERSELF.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING BACK TO YALE:
RESHMA SAUJANI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> ALL RIGHT.
I JUST HAVE TO SAY IT.
DAMN, IT'S HOT!
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE.
I WANT TO THANK PRESIDENT
SALOVEY, THE DEANS, THE
DISWISHED GUESTS AND I WANT TO
GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT-OUT TO OUR
FAMILY.
I'M AN HONORED TO BE HERE WITH
MY HUSBAND, MY SON, MY FATHER,
MY SISTER AND MY NIECE.
THE TRUTH IS, ESPECIALLY AFTER
THE PAST TWO YEARS, NONE OF US
GET TO THIS STAGE ALONE.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
SACRIFICE.
A LOT OF COMMITMENT.
A LOT OF LOVE IN OUR JOURNEY TO
GET TO THIS STAGE.
SO I WANT TO RECOGNIZE ALL OF
THE PARENTS AND FAMILY WHO GOT
US HERE, AND FRIENDS.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
BEFORE I GET STARTED, I WANTED
TO GET OUT THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM.
I'M SURE SOME OF YOU ARE, WERE
A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED WHEN YOU
FOUND OUT THAT I WAS GOING TO
BE YOUR CLASS DAY SPEAKER.
MAYBE YOU EVEN THOUGHT "WHO'S
THAT?" AND GOOLED ME ON THE WAY
OVER HERE.
I GET IT.
YOU'VE HAD SOME PRETTY AMAZING
CLASS DAY SPEAKERS.
YOU'VE HAD YOUR FAIR SHARE OF
PRESIDENTS INCLUDING BIDEN AND
CLINTON AND OF COURSE HOW CAN
WE FORGET BILL CLINTON?
BUT TODAY YOU GET SOMETHING
EVEN MORE POWERFUL THAN A
PRESIDENT.
YOU GET A PISSED OFF MOM LIVING
IN AMERICA.
SO CONGRATULATIONS!
[  CHEERS ]
SO A LOT HAS CHANGED IN THE 20
YEARS SINCE I GRADUATED FROM
THIS INCREDIBLE UNIVERSITY.
BUT I SUSPECT NOT MUCH
HAS CHANGED ABOUT THE KIND OF
STUDENTS THAT COME TO YALE.
I KNOW THIS MAY COME AS A SHOCK
TO YOU, BUT I,
TOO, WAS AN INSUFFERABLE
OVERACHIEVER.
I GRADUATED COLLEGE IN THREE
YEARS AS VALEDICTORIAN, AND
I SET OUT TO ATTEND THE
BEST LAW SCHOOL IN THE
COUNTRY.
IN 1989 I HAD GOTTEN MY HANDS
ON A
COPY OF THE U.S. NEWS & WORLD
REPORT, AND THERE IT WAS,
RIGHT AT THE TOP.
YALE.
I TOOK THAT PAGE AND I TACKED
IT TO MY BEDROOM WALL IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL.
LIKE I SAID: INSUFFERABLE.
I APPLIED TO YALE
NOT ONCE, NOT TWICE,
BUT THREE SEPARATE TIMES.
I ONLY GOT CLOSE WHEN I PLEADED
MY CASE TO THE DEAN OF
ADMISSIONS AT A FUNERAL.
SO CLASSY, RIGHT?
THE DEAN MADE ME A DEAL.
HE SAID: GET INTO ANY LAW
SCHOOL IN THE COUNTRY AND I'LL
LET YOU TRANSFER TO YALE.
SO I GRINDED AND GRINDED,
AND I GOT TO MY CLASS AT
GEORGETOWN LAW.
ONLY AFTER ALL OF THAT
DID YALE FINALLY LET ME IN.
BIG MISTAKE ON THEIR PART,
MY CAMPAIGN TO GET
INTO YALE WAS THE
FIRST OF MANY FOR ME.
I RAN FOR OFFICE TWICE.
I STARTED AN ORGANIZATION TO
TEACH GIRLS TO CODE.
AND MOST RECENTLY,
I'VE BUILT A MOVEMENT
TO SUPPORT MOTHERS
AND WORKING WOMEN
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I LOVE ADVOCACY.
I LOVE FIGHTING FOR PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY WOMEN AND GIRLS.
AND I LOVE THAT CHANGE IS
POSSIBLE HERE;
THAT PUSHING AND
AGITATING FOR THINGS
TO BE DIFFERENT IS A
BIG PART OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO LIVE IN AMERICA.
“TO FORM A MORE
PERFECT UNION,” RIGHT?
OR HOW ABOUT THIS ONE?
MAYBE THE MOST FAMOUS
LINE SAID BY A U.S.
PRESIDENT:
SAY IT WITH ME.
“ASK NOT WHAT YOUR COUNTRY CAN
DO FOR YOU ”
BUT WHAT YOU CAN DO FOR YOUR
COUNTRY."
.
SO ICONIC.
SO CATCHY.
AND SO DEEPLY WOVEN INTO THE
AMERICA'S CONSCIOUSNESS, THAT
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE
FROM HERE, OR FROM ANOTHER
NATION, YOU PROBABLY KNOW THOSE
WORDS BY HEART.
BUT CAN I TELL YOU SOMETHING?
LATELY, WHEN I HEAR JFK'S
FAMOUS WORDS, IT MAKES ME KIND
OF
ANGRY.
BECAUSE I CAN'T HELP BUT PLACE
THOSE WORDS IN THEIR HISTORICAL
CONTEXT, AND COMPARE THEM TO
THE TIMES WE'RE LIVING THROUGH
TODAY, AND HEAR THEM JUST A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY.
LET'S REWIND THE TAPE.
IT'S JANUARY, 1961:
KENNEDY'S INAUGURATION.
AMERICA IS FEELING THE
AFTERSHOCKS OF A
GENERATION-DEFINING CRISIS.
THERE'S TENSION ABROAD IN
RUSSIA AND CHINA.
AND THERE'S TENSION BACK HERE
AT HOME,
TOO, AROUND RACIAL INEQUALITY
AND THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
THE BIG DIFFERENCE THOUGH
BETWEEN BACK THEN AND NOW, IS
BACK THEN, AMERICA WAS
GETTING THE JOB DONE.
THINK ABOUT THAT ERA:
POST-WORLD WAR II,
THE UNITED STATES WAS LITERALLY
CREATING A WHOLE NEW WORLD
ORDER, WITH INSTITUTIONS LIKE
THE UN, NATO, WTO, IMF,
AND WORLD BANK.
WE WERE SPRINTING TO WIN THE
SPACE RACE AND DEVELOPED
LIFESAVING VACCINES
AGAINST POLIO AND MEASLES.
BACK WHEN WE WERE INTO THAT
KIND OF THING.
WE WERE INCREASING SOCIAL
SECURITY, RAISING THE MAXIMUM
MAXIMUM WAGE, CREATING FOOD
STAMPS,
INTERSTATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM,
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT --
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON AND ON.
AMERICA WAS DOING A LOT.
NOT ENOUGH,
AND NOT FOR EVERYONE.
BY IT WAS DOING A LOT.
SO IT'S NO WONDER THAT IN THE
EARLY '60s WHEN PEW ASKED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE: DO YOU TRUST
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
WHAT'S RIGHT?
75% OF AMERICANS SAID YES.
AMAZING.
75%!
SO IN THAT CONTEXT, WHEN JFK
TAKES THE STAGE AND HE
ADDRESSES THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FOR THE FIRST TIME AS THEIR
U.S. PRESIDENT, AND HE ASKED
THEM TO STAND UP FOR THEIR
COUNTRY, IT RESONATES!
IT REVERBERATES.
FOR DECADES IT STILL REVERB
RATES.
IT'S QUOTED CONSTANTLY.
I JUST DID A MINUTE AGO.
BUT THE QUESTION IS, DOES IT
RESONATE?
LAST YEAR PEW ASKED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE SAME
QUESTION.
DO YOU TRUST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT?
THIS TIME ONLY 22% OF AMERICANS
SAID YES.
NOW, I'VE RUN FOR OFFICE.
I'VE SERVED IN GOVERNMENT.
I AM THE FIRST GENERATION
DAUGHTER OF POLITICAL
REFUGEES.
THIS COUNTRY LITERALLY SAVED
MY PARENTS' LIVES.
I'M THE DEFINITION
OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
SO BELIEVE ME, I WANT TO BE
IN THAT 22%.
I DO.
BUT I'M ALSO A WORKING MOM,
LIVING IN THE ONLY
INDUSTRIALIZED
NATION THAT DOESN'T
OFFER PAID LEAVE, LET ALONE
FLEXIBILITY.
AND YOU'RE STUDENTS GRADUATING
WITH BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
STUDENT LOAN DEBT, SOMETHING
THAT THE GOVERNMENT CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT, BUT WON'T.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY,
NEW HAVEN, WHERE
HALF THE POPULATION
LOST THEIR JOBS IN COVID,
AND MANY STILL
CAN'T PAY THE RENT.
IN A COUNTRY -- IN A STATE THAT
HAS THE LARGEST INCOME
INEQUALITY IN THE COUNTRY.
IN A NATION WHERE MILLIONS
ARE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS, DROWNING UNDER MEDICAL
DEBT, IN A NATION THAT RATHER
FORCE BIRTH -- AND SOMETIMES
EVEN FORCE DEATH, THAN GIVE US
AUTONOMY OVER OUR OWN BODIES.
[  CHEERS ]
IN A WORLD WITH RACIAL
INJUSTICE, VIOLENT
AUTHORITARIANISM, AND THE
CLIMATE CRISIS THAT IS GETTING
WORSE BY THE SECOND.
ALL OF THIS WAS BEFORE A
ONCE-IN-A-CENTURY
PANDEMIC THAT THE GOVERNMENT
REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO MANAGE
EFFECTIVELY.
SO, ASK US WHAT WE CAN DO FOR
OUR COUNTRY?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
YOUR GENERATION HAS MARCHED
FOR BLACK LIVES, LABOR RIGHTS,
CLIMATE RIGHTS.
YOU'VE CHALLENGED THE STIGMA
AROUND MENTAL ILLNESS.
YOU'VE HELD POWERFUL
INSTITUTIONS ACCOUNTABLE,
INCLUDING YOUR VERY OWN
UNIVERSITY.
[  CHEERS ]
CLASS OF 2022, JFK'S WORDS
WERE NOT FOR YOU.
INSTEAD, HE WOULD WANT YOU
TO ASK WHAT YOUR COUNTRY
CAN DO FOR YOU.
BECAUSE I BET HE WOULD AGREE,
IT SHOULD BE
DOING A HELL OF A LOT MORE.
IT SHOULD BE PROVIDING
CHILDCARE AND ABORTION CARE,
SAVING OUR PLANET AND OUR
DEMOCRACY, MAKING THE RICH
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE,
AND OUR WORKPLACES PAY UP.
AND YES, MAKING WORKPLACES PAY
UP.
SO YES, ASK YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES,
STATE, LOCAL, AND YES, EVEN
YOUR PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN, OR
WHATEVER TICKET ELI SABIN
RUNS ON IN THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS -- ASK THEM, ASK THEM TO
TEAR DOWN THESE BROKEN
STRUCTURES AND BUILD UP
EQUITABLE ONES.
AND ASK YOUR PARTNERS, YOUR
COMMUNITY, AND YOUR WORKPLACES
TO DO THE SAME.
AND I KNOW YOU WILL.
BUT HERE'S THE CATCH.
DON'T DO IT NOW.
YOU'RE NOT READY.
DON'T GET ME WRONG --
I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
GENERATION, A CLASS OF LEADERS.
EAGER TO USE THE GIFT AND
PRIVILEGE OF YOUR EDUCATION
TO GO OUT INTO THE WORLD
WITH OPEN-MINDEDNESS, COURAGE,
AND CONTEMPLATION.
BUT BEFORE YOU ASK WHAT
YOUR COUNTRY CAN DO FOR YOU,
YOU HAVE TO ASK WHAT YOU CAN DO
FOR YOURSELF.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
YOU KNOW I TOLD YOU ABOUT THE
STORY HOW I GOT HERE, APPLIED
TO YALE THREE TIMES, TOP OF MY
CLASS AT GEORGETOWN, BLAH BLAH
BLAH?
WELL, HERE'S THE
REST OF THE STORY.
MY TIME AT GEORGETOWN WAS
MISERABLE.
I WAS SO FOCUSED ON GETTING
INTO YALE, THAT I DIDN'T DO
BASIC THINGS, LIKE SLEEP EIGHT
HOURS A DAY, EAT THREE MEALS,
MAKE A SINGLE FRIEND.
SO BY THE TIME I GOT TO YALE,
I WAS EXHAUSTED.
SO I DID THE BEST THING I HAVE
EVER DONE FOR MYSELF: I JUST
STOPPED.
OH, I LIKE YOU.
AND I WENT FROM HAVING NO
FRIENDS, LITERALLY NO FRIENDS
IN DC, TO HAVING A GROUP OF
INSEPARABLE GIRLFRIENDS HERE IN
NEW HAVEN.
THE TEN OF US WERE
SOME OF THE ONLY WOMEN OF COLOR
AT YALE LAW.
AND BACK AT HOME, WE WERE
SHINING
EXAMPLES OF PERFECTION.
BUT BECAUSE WE HAD GIVEN UP SO
MUCH TO GET TO THIS
INSTITUTION, WHEN WE GOT HERE,
WE HAD NOTHING LEFT TO GIVE.
SO INSTEAD,
WE PARTIED EVERY
THURSDAY NIGHT AT GYPSY.
WE DANCED TO J.LO, MISSY ELLIOT
AND BRITNEY SPEARS.
WE SKIPPED CLASS TO WATCH "SEX
AND THE CITY" AND
"THE SOPRANOS."
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE,
I CARED MORE ABOUT INVESTING
IN MYSELF AND MY RELATIONSHIPS
THAN INVESTING IN MY CAREER.
AND IT FELT INCREDIBLE.
NOW, BECAUSE I CHOSE THAT
PATH, I DIDN'T FULFILL
A LOT OF YALE LAW
RITES OF PASSAGE.
I WASN'T EDITOR OF THE
LAW REVIEW.
I DIDN'T GET A CLERKSHIP.
IN FACT I ASK A PROFESSOR TO
WRITE A RECOMMENDATION FOR ME.
AND WHILE HE WROTE ME A LETTER,
HE RECOMMENDED NOT HIRING ME.
I THINK HE STILL WORKS HERE.
ANYWAY, BACK TO MY COMMENCEMENT
SPEECH.
SO, YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT
I LEARNED MY LESSON.
THAT I WOULD HAVE LEFT YALE
WITH
MY BATTERY RECHARGED,
READY TO GO CHANGE THE WORLD.
WELL, I LEFT YALE AND I WENT TO
GO WORK AT A WHITE-SHOE LAW
FIRM WHERE I GOT FIRED, BECAUSE
MY HEART WAS SO NOT INTO IT.
YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT AFTER
THAT I WOULD BE READY TO GO
FIGHT THE GOOD FIGHT.
WELL, FIGHT I DID WITH MY
BOSSES AT MY NEW SOULLESS HEDGE
FUND JOB.
WHY DID I KEEP DOING THAT?
WHY DID I KEEP FALLING INTO
THIS HUSTLE
CULTURE TRAP?
BACK THEN,
I DIDN'T THINK I HAD A CHOICE.
I HAD SPENT MY WHOLE LIFE
STUDYING HOW TO BE A
“GIRLBOSS”: HOW TO HAVE
IT ALL, AND LOOK GOOD
DOING IT.
THAT I THOUGHT MY DEGREE AT
YALE WOULD JUST UNLOCK A
LIFETIME OF MORE.
MORE TITLES AND PROMOTIONS.
MORE ACCOLADES AND MAGAZINE
PROFILES.
THANKFULLY, THAT ASPIRATION
IS NO LONGER IN FASHION --
I'M PRETTY SURE YOU'D RATHER
WEAR A HARVARD T-SHIRT RIGHT
NOW THAN A
“GIRLBOSS” ONE.
BUT THAT SENTIMENT THAT YOU
SHOULD BE AMBITIOUS BUT
LIKABLE, RELENTLESS BUT
EFFORTLESS, STILL LIVES ON.
AND WHEN WE CAN'T BALANCE
HAVING IT ALL, WE THINK THAT'S
A PERSONAL FAILURE, RATHER THAN
A STRUCTURAL ONE.
FOR SO LONG, I WAS SO ASHAMED
OF MY TIME HERE AT YALE.
I THOUGHT I SHOULD HAVE DONE
MORE.
TRIED HARDER.
BUT I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR MY
TIME, EXACTLY AS IT WAS.
BECAUSE IT TAUGHT ME THAT WHEN
I TAKE CARE OF MYSELF, I CAN
BETTER TAKE CARE OF OTHERS.
AND FIGHT FOR THEM TOO.
IT TAUGHT ME TO BE A BETTER
LEADER, A BETTER ADVOCATE, A
BETTER WIFE, A BETTER MOTHER, A
BETTER NEIGHBOR, A BETTER
FRIEND.
ALL I EVER WANTED WAS THIS
DEGREE.
BUT I'M FAR MORE GRATEFUL FOR
THE LESSON.
TO BE SURE, SELF-CARE
HAS BEEN CO-OPTED BEYOND
RECOGNITION, BY BILLION DOLLAR
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE TEG YOU
TO PRACTICE SELF-CARE AND THEN
WORK 80 HOURS A WEEK.
THEY WANT YOU TO
FIX WHAT THEY'VE BROKEN.
THAT'S NOT SELF-CARE;
THAT'S CORPORATE STRATEGY.
[  CHEERS ]
CLASS OF 2022, YOU DON'T NEED
FIXING. YOU WON'T NEED FIXING.
BUT AFTER THE PAST TWO YEARS,
YOU WILL NEED HEALING.
WE ALL WILL.
HEALING IS DOING WHATEVER
YOUR BODY, YOUR SOUL, YOUR
MIND, YOUR SPIRIT NEEDS TO
RECHARGE.
IT'S REEXAMINING YOUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH YOURSELF,
YOUR COMMUNITY, YOUR WORLD,
YOUR NATION, YOUR FAITH.
OUTSIDE MY HINDU TEMPLE IN
QUEENS, THERE'S A STATUE OF A
TURTLE.
AND THE TURTLE IS THERE TO
REMIND YOU THAT SOMETIMES
YOU'RE AT YOUR STRONGEST WHEN
YOU WITHDRAW.
THAT YOU'VE GOT TO GO INWARD
FIRST BEFORE CHARGING FORWARD.
GRADUATES, GO INWARD.
HEAL YOURSELF.
ONLY THEN CAN YOU HEAL THE
NATION.
BECAUSE YES, YES, YES.
YOUR COUNTRY NEEDS YOU.
JUST NOT IN THE WAY JFK
IMAGINED.
YOUR COUNTRY NEEDS YOU TO TAKE
CARE OF EACH OTHER, AND
REIMAGINE A WORLD THAT BETTER
TAKES CARE OF US.
YOUR COUNTRY NEEDS YOU TO BREAK
THAT HUSTLE CULTURE TRAP, AND
BUILD NEW WORKPLACES, STRONGER
COMMUNITIES, NEW SOCIAL
PROGRAMS.
SYSTEMS THAT SUPPORT OUR MENTAL
HEALTH, RATHER THAN TEAR IT
DOWN.
OUR COUNTRY NEEDS YOU TO
FIGHT FOR RIGHTS, RIGHTS
SHOCKINGLY WE CAN'T TAKE FOR
GRANTED IN 2022.
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHAT YOU
CHOOSE, LOVE WHO YOU LOVE, BE
WHO YOU ARE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT OUR
STRUGGLES ARE INTERTWINED, AND
SO IS OUR PATH TO FREEDOM.
OUR COUNTRY NEEDS YOU BE
BRAVER THAN I WAS WHEN I
LEFT THIS PLACE.
I WISH I HAD YOUR WISDOM TO
ADVOCATE FOR MY MENTAL HEALTH,
TO SET
BOUNDARIES, TO FIGHT
FOR MY RIGHTS AT HOME, AND AT
WORK.
I WISH I HAD YOUR
PERSPECTIVE TO KNOW WHAT TRULY
MATTERS, TO KNOW WHICH FIGHTS
WERE ENERGIZING ME, AND
WHICH ONES WERE EXPLOITING ME.
I WISH I HAD PERMISSION
PERMISSION TO BE SELFISH.
AND NOT SELFISH IN THE EGO MAN
EYE KAL OR CYNICAL SENSE, BUT
SELFISH IN THE PUREST SENSE OF
THE WORLD, TO TAKE CARE OF
MYSELF, SO I COULD BETTER GO
OUT IN THE WORLD AND DO THE
WORK.
IN THE WORDS OF THE
BRILLIANT AUDRE LORDE:
"CARING FOR MYSELF IS NOT
LF-INDULGENCE, IT IS
SELF-PRESERVATION, AND THAIS
AN ACT OF POLICAL WARFARE."
CLASS OF 22,HIS IS MY GT
TO YOU IIVE YOU PERSSN
TO BSEISH.
TO ASK MORE FRO OTH,
ESCILY THOSE W HAVE MOR
GE.
TO BUILD SYSTE AROUND CE
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO TEND TO YOUR OWN BRILLIANT
FLAME, BEFORE SHARING
YOUR LIGHT WITH THE REST
OF US.
I TRUST --
I KNOW THAT YOU WILL USE THIS
GIFT WISELY.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU FOR THOSE VERY
INSPIRING WORDS, FOR REMINDING
US TO CARE FOR EACH OTHER AND
THROUGH YOUR OWN EXAMPLE
SHOWING HOW WE CAN DO SO.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
AUTHENTICITY AND POWER.
AND I'VE BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF
THESE EVENTS.
YOU ARE CERTAINLY ONE OF OUR
BEST SPEAKERS.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALL RIGHT, SENIORS,
I HAVE SOME BUSINESS
THAT I NEED TO CONDUCT WITH
YOU.
BUT FIRST I WANT TO ASK THE
FOLLOWING STUDENTS TO COME UP
TO THE SEATS IN THE FRONT ROW.
CHIA AMISOLA
OF SAYBROOK COLLEGE
KAYLEY DELAY
OF MORSE COLLEGE
JAELEN KING
OF BENJAMIN FRANKLIN COLLEGE
MATTHEW JOHN KING
OF EZRA STILES COLLEGE
GABRIEL LOUIS KLAPHOLZ
OF BRANFORD COLLEGE
EC MINGO
OF EZRA STILE COLLEGE
MARY ELIZABETH ORSAK
OF PIERSON COLLEGE
AZAR SWAIN
OF TIMOTHY DWIGHT COLLEGE
ALEX WHITTINGTON
OF PIERSON COLLEGE
SARAH MING-XIN ZHAO
OF BERKELEY COLLEGE
AS THEY GET SETTLED, FOR ALL OF
YOU, WE HAVE TO DO A LITTLE
DRESS REHEARSAL FOR TOMORROW.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY COMMENCEMENT
BACK HERE IN THIS SPACE.
THERE IS
GOING TO BE A POINT
WHEN I STAND UP HERE IN
FRONT OF PRESIDENT SALOVEY
AND PRESENT YOU TO HIM
SO THAT YOU CAN RECEIVE
YOUR DEGREES.
SO LISTEN UP.
THE LAST TWO SENTENCES OF MY
REQUEST TO PRESIDENT SALOVEY
ARE GOING TO BE:
"THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
BY THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE
AND APPROVED BY THE
CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU,
BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT,
TO CONFER UP THEM THESE
DEGREES."
WHEN YOU HEAR THESE WORDS --
"CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES" --
I WANT TO HEAR YOU,
LOUD AND CLEAR;
YOU'RE GRADUATING.
SO LET'S PRACTICE.
"THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
BY THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE
AND APPROVED BY THE
CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU,
BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT,
TO CONFER UP THEM THESE
DEGREES."
[  CHEERS ]
I'M SORRY, YOU'RE MUTED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET'S TRY AGAIN.
"THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
BY THE FACULTY OF YALE
COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU,
BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT,
TO CONFER UPON THEM
THESE DEGREES.
"
[  CHEERS ]
>> WILL KALEY DELAY AND AZAR
SWAIN PLEASE COME UP TO THE
STAGE?
[  CHEERS AND
[ APPLAUSE ]
]
I AM THRILLED TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THE NELLIE P. ELLIOT AND
WILLIAM NEELY MALLORY
AWARDS FOR THE SENIOR WOMAN
AND MAN WHOSE EXCELLENCE
IN THE FIELD OF ATHLETICS, AND
IN THEIR LIFE AT YALE, BEST
REPRESENT THE HIGHEST IDEALS
OF SPORTSMANSHIP AND YALE
TRADITION GO THIS YEAR TO THE
TWO WALKING UP HERE:
KALEY DELAY
AND AZAR SWAIN.
[  CHEERS AROUND
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THROUGH HARD WORK AND
DETERMINATION, SHE MOLDED
HERSELF INTO ONE OF THE TOP
DISTANCE RUNNERS IN THE
NATION.
SHE IS AN NCAA CROSS-COUNTRY
ALL-AMERICAN.
SHE WON AN INCREDIBLE
10TH PLACE NATIONALLY IN
CROSS-COUNTRY. SHE WON
BACK-TO-BACK IVY LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIPS IN CROSS-COUNTRY
IN 2019 AND 2021.
SHE WAS THE IVY LEAGUE
CHAMPION IN THE 3,000 METERS
IN 2020 AND 2022.
SHE HOLDS THE YALE RECORD
IN 3,000 METERS, 5,000 METERS
INDOORS, 5,000 METERS
OUTDOORS, AND 3,000 METERS
IN THE STEEPLECHASE.
[  CHEERS ]
SHE HOLDS THE NO. 2 ALL-TIME
MARK IN THE IVY LEAGUE
IN BOTH THE STEEPLECHASE
AND THE 5,000 METER INDOORS.
SHE WAS A 2020 OLYMPIC TRIALS
QUALIFIER IN THE 3,000-METER
STEEPLECHASE.
SHE DID ALL OF THIS WHILE
HOLDING DOWN AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ENGINEERING MAJOR, RESEARCHING
AT THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
AND BEING AN ONEXYS STUDENT
COACH
FOR REPRESENTING TREMENDOUS
ATHLETIC ACCOMPLISHMENT
ON THE FIELD, AND FOR BEING
EVERYTHING THAT A YALE
STUDENT ATHLETE SHOULD BE OFF
THE FIELD, YALE TAKES PRIDE
IN AWARDING THE
NELLIE P. ELLIOT AWARD
TO KALEY DELAY.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AZAR.
HE IS ONE OF THE
ALL-TIME GREAT YALE
BASKETBALL PLAYERS.
HE HELPED LEAD HIS TEAM
THROUGH AN INCREDIBLE
SEASON, IN WHICH THE BULLDOGS
WON 19 GAMES, CAPTURED THE
IVY LEAGUE TOURNAMENT TITLE
WITH A THRILLING VICTORY OVER
PRINCETON, AND EARNED AN NCAA
TOURNAMENT BID FOR THE THIRD
STRAIGHT TIME.
[  CHEERS ]
HE PLAYED
IN MORE GAMES IN YALE
HISTORY THAN ANY OTHER YALE
BASKETBALL PLAYER EVER --
THAT'S 121 GAMES, TO BE EXACT.
WAS PART
OF FOUR CHAMPIONSHIPS:
TWO REGULAR-SEASON AND
TWO TOURNAMENT TITLES.
HE AVERAGED 19.2 POINTS
PER GAME HIS SENIOR YEAR.
HE HAS A REMARKABLE RECORD
OF 271 CAREER THREES,
WHICH IS FIRST ALL-TIME
AT YALE.
[  CHEERS ]
HE WAS IVY LEAGUE
TOURNAMENT MVP IN 2022 WITH
1,529 CAREER POINTS. AND, HE
WAS
A FINALIST FOR THE LOU HENSON
AWARD FOR BEST MID MAJOR PLAYER
IN THE COUNTRY.
LIKE KALEY, HE TOOK A YEAR OFF
DURING COVID IN ORDER TO RETURN
TO HELP HIS TEAM HAVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE CHANCE TO REPEAT AS
IVY LEAGUE CHAMPIONS.
HE EARNED TREMENDOUS RESPECT
FROM OPPOSING COACHES AND
PLAYERS ALIKE DUE TO HIS
COMPETITIVE NATURE AND
TALENTS ON THE COURT AND HIS
EXCELLENT SPORTSMANSHIP.
AND HE WAS, IN ADDITION,
A FAN FAVORITE, SOMEONE WHO
GARNERED THE RESPECT AND
ADMIRATION OF ALL BULLDOG FANS.
FOR HIS TREMENDOUS ATHLETIC
ACCOMPLISHMENT, HIS
RELENTLESSLY HARD WORK,
AND HIS STATURE AS A COMPETITOR
OF GREAT INTEGRITY AND HONOR,
YALE TAKES GREAT PRIDE IN
AWARDING THE
WILLIAM NEELY MALLORY AWARD
TO AZAR SWAIN.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
JAELEN KING AND EC MINGO, WILL
YOU PLEASE COME UP TO THE
STAGE?
[  CHEERS ]
THE NAKANISHI PRIZE IS AWARDED
TO TWO GRADUATING SENIORS WHO,
WHILE MAINTAINING HIGH ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT, HAVE PROVIDED
EXEMPLARY LEADERSHIP IN
ENHANCING RACE OR ETHNIC
RELATIONS AT YALE COLLEGE.
THIS YEAR'S PRIZES ARE
AWARDED TO JAELEN KING OF
BENJAMIN FRANKLIN COLLEGE AND
EC MINGO OF EZRA STILES
COLLEGE.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
JAELEN KING, A MOLECULAR,
CELLULAR, AND DEVELOPMENTAL
BIOLOGY MAJOR, IS AN
ADVOCATE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND COMMUNITY AT BOTH YALE
AND WITHIN THE NEW HAVEN
JAELEN HAS BEEN AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE BLACK
STUDENT ALLIANCE AT YALE,
BLACK PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AT YALE,
AND BLACK STUDENTS FOR
DISARMAMENT AT YALE.
HE HAS ALSO BEEN THE PRIMARY
COORDINATOR OF COALITION
BUILDING EFFORTS AMONG CULTURAL
CENTERS, ACROSS CAMPUS, AND
TOGETHER WITH ORGANIZATIONS
IN NEW HAVEN.
THROUGH HIS WORK, HE HAS
AMPLIFIED THE VOICES OF BLACK
WOMEN ON CAMPUS AND IN NEW
HAVEN, CENTERED THE EXPERIENCES
OF BLACK NEW HAVEN IN RELATION
TO YALE, AND ADVOCATED FOR
RESIDENTS'
RESPECTFUL TREATMENT.
AND WELL-BEING.
JAELEN IS ALSO PROUD MEMBER
OF THE ETA ALPHA LAMBDA
CHAPTER OF ALPHA PHI ALPHA,
INC.
AND WAS AN INTEGRAL MEMBER OF
THE BLACK MEN'S UNION FROM HIS
FIRST STEPS ONTO CAMPUS.
HE DEVELOPED A CO-CURRICULUM
TO EDUCATE BMU STUDENTS ON
MASCULINITY AND ON RACIALIZED
GENDER ISSUES, INSTITUTING
WEBINARS, A BOOK CLUB, AND
MENTORING TO EDUCATE HIS
ORGANIZATION AND TO HOLD HIS
PEERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS AND THEIR LEARNING,
AND THEIR FUTURE ADVOCACY FOR
THE BLACK COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY SERVICE
AND LEADERSHIP, YALE COLLEGE IS
HONORED TO AWARD THE
NAKANISHI PRIZE TO
JAELEN KING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
EVAN CRAIG MINGO GRADUATES
WITH DISTINCTION IN BOTH
HIS MAJORS.
ETHNICITY, RACE AND MIGRATION.
AND PSYCHOLOGY.
WITHIN AND BEYOND HIS ACADEMIC
WORK, EC HAS GIVEN VOICE,
LABOR, AND LEADERSHIP TO THE
DIFFICULT, OFTEN UNSEEN WORK OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
EC HAS CREATED WORKSHOPS ON
ANTI-BLACKNESS IN INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT
AFRO-INDIGENOUS STUDENTS
AT THE NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURAL
CENTER.
HE HAS
WORKED ON DIVERSITY, EQUITY
AND INCLUSION INITIATIVES FOR
THE COMMUNITY AND CONSENT
EDUCATORS PROGRAM AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PSYCHOLOGY.
EC WAS SELECT AS ONE OF THE
INAUGURAL COHORT OF THE
COALITION OF ALLYSHIP
OF THE COALITION OF ALLYSHIP
ADVOCATES TO DEVELOP
APPROACHES TO ENHANCING RACE
AND ETHNIC RELATIONS ON CAMPUS.
AND HE ALSO ESTABLISHED THE
STUDENT ORGANIZATION
BLACKOUT TO PROVIDE A SPACE
WHERE BLACK LGBTQIA+ PEERS
COULD ENGAGE WITH THIS
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS SPECIFIC
INTERSECTION OF IDENTITY.
IN ALL HIS ROLES ON CAMPUS,
EC HAS RAISED QUESTIONS AND
ADDRESSED THE PROBLEMS OF
DISCRIMINATION
COLORISM, TRANSPHOBIA,
HOMOPHOBIA, CLASSISM,
AND OTHER INEQUITIES
THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE GO
UNADDRESSED.
HIS AIM IS
ALWAYS TO GENERATE CRITICAL
CONVERSATIONS, PLAN PRODUCTIVE
STRATEGY AND RECONCILE HIS
PEERS.
FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY SERVICE
AND LEADERSHIP, YALE COLLEGE
IS HONORED TO AWARD THE
NAKANISHI PRIZE TO
EVAN CRAIG MINGO.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THE JAMES ANDREW HAAS PRIZE
IS AWARDED ANNUALLY TO “THAT
MEMBER OF THE SENIOR CLASS IN
YALE COLLEGE WHOSE BREADTH OF
INTELLECTUAL ACHIEVEMENT,
STRENGTH OF CHARACTER, AND
FUNDAMENTAL HUMANITY SHALL BE
ADJUDGED BY THE FACULTY TO HAVE
PROVIDED LEADERSHIP FOR HIS OR
HER FELLOW STUDENTS, INSPIRING
IN THEM A LOVE OF LEARNING AND
CONCERN FOR OTHERS.”
THIS YEAR THE HAAS PRIZE IS
AWARDED TO ARYA SINGH OF PAULI
MURRAY COLLEGE.
ARYA SINGH GRADUATES
SUMMA CUM LAUDE
WITH DISTINCTION
IN HER MAJOR, HISTORY OF
SCIENCE, MEDICINE, AND PUBLIC
HEALTH, AND AS AN EDUCATION
STUDIES SCHOLAR.
SHE RECEIVED LAST FALL THE
FRANCIS GORDON BROWN
PRIZE, FOR HER “INTELLECTUAL
ABILITY, HIGH PERSONHOOD,
CAPACITY FOR LEADERSHIP, AND
SERVICE TO THE UNIVERSITY.”
ARYA HAS ALWAYS PROMOTED
ACCESSIBILITY AND EQUITY IN
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS,
ASKING HOW TO HUMANIZE
MEDICINE AND LEAVE FEWER
PATIENTS FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS. SHE HAS INSPIRED
PEERS, MENTORS, AND
COLLEAGUES THROUGH HER
WORK WITH CHAPEL HAVEN'S
ASPERGER SYNDROME ADULT
TRANSITION PROGRAM, FOCUS,
AND DEFY DISABILITY EMPOWERMENT
FOR YALE. AS PRESIDENT OF THE
YALE UNDERGRADUATE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION, SHE EXPANDED THE
ORGANIZATION'S REACH BY FORMING
PARTNERING WITH THE
CONNECTICUT VETERANS' LEGAL
CLINIC.
SHE ALSO SERVES
ON THE NEW HAVEN COMMISSION ON
DISABILITIES, TO WHICH SHE WAS
APPOINTED BY NEW HAVEN'S MAYOR
AND HER 2020 CHILDREN'S BOOK,
OFFERS
CHILDREN A BETTER WAY TO
UNDERSTAND INFORMED
CONSENT FOR RESEARCH STUDIES.
NEXT YEAR, SHE WILL FINISH HER
MASTER'S IN PUBLIC HEALTH
AT THE YALE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR HER OUTSTANDING ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENTS, FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND SERVICE,
AND FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
ACCESSIBILITY, EQUITY, AND
INCLUSIVITY, YALE COLLEGE IS
PROUD TO BESTOW THE
JAMES ANDREW HAAS
MEMORIAL PRIZE UPON
ARYA CHANNENG SINGH.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> YALE UNIVERSITY!
WHAT'S THE GOOD WORD!
WAIT, WHAT ARE
YOU GUYS DOING HERE?
CHASE: GIVING THE COMEDIC
REFLECTION?
THE LAST FOUR YEARS WERE SO
BRUTAL AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
JOKES TO MAKE.
MACRINA: WHAT DO YOU MEAN? THE
LAST FOUR YEARS WERE ENTIRELY
AWESOME!
KYLE: WE HAVE SO MANY FUN
MEMORIES TO JOKE ABOUT!
KYLE AND MACRINA: BOOLA BOOLA
WOO!
IHEA: FIRST OF ALL, NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CHASE: NO ONE'S SAID THAT SINCE
BULLDOG DAYS.
IHEA: AND SECOND OF ALL, DO YOU
SEE HOW TIRED OUR CLASSMATES
LOOK?
MACRINA: NO, THAT'S JUST HOW
THEY LOOK WITHOUT THEIR MASKS!
KYLE: CAN I JUST SAY, CLASS OF
2022, I THINK YOU ALL LOOK
GREAT
IN YOUR HATS AND GOWNS
CHASE: BUT ONLY THE ORIGINALS.
2021-PLUS ONES, WHY ARE YOU
STILL HERE?
YOU LOOK OLD.
GET A JOB!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY.
WE DON'T WANT
TO BORE YOU WITH ANY REMINDERS
OF THIS TERRIBLE PANDEMIC, SO
LET'S JUST GET ALL THE COVID
STUFF OUT OF THE WAY, YEAH?
ALL: COVID COVID COVID,
UNPRECEDENTED, HEALTHY YALE,
IT'S OKAY NOT TO BE OKAY.
MASK UP.
BOW WOW WOW.
[  CHEERS ]
IHEA: FEELS GOOD TO GET THAT
OUT
OF OUR SYSTEM!
MACRINA: I KINDA LIKED THE
PANDEMIC.
CHASE: YOU DID?
>> YEAH.
I FOLLOWED YALE'S
EXAMPLE AND BOUGHT ZOOM STOCK
EARLY ON.
>> YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T MIND
MASK-WEARING EITHER.
WHEN MY FRIENDS DIDN'T
LAUGH AT MY JOKES, I COULD JUST
ASSUME THEY WERE SILENT SMILERS
AND I COULDN'T SEE IT.
>> OKAY.
BUT ALSO A LOT OF THINGS
DURING OUR TIME AT YALE SUCKED
THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PANDEMIC.
>> YEAH.
LIKE FIRST-YEAR FORMAL?
>> CHASE, WE WENT TO FIRST-YEAR
FORMAL TOGETHER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CHASE: YEAH
KYLE: GUYS, FIRST YEAR WASN'T
ALL THAT BAD.
>> YEAH.
REMEMBER OUR FIRST YEAR
MATRICULATION CEREMONY WHEN
THAT
RABBIT/DUCK IMAGE WAS
DISPLAYED FOR WHAT WE CAN ONLY
IMAGINE WAS THE 30TH YEAR IN A
ROW?
>> YEAH.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO TEACH US
ABOUT PERSPECTIVE, BUT IT WAS
REALLY JUST INSPIRATIONAL TO ME
AS AN
ENGLISH MAJOR BECAUSE
IT SHOWS YOU CAN REUSE OLD
MATERIAL AND HOPE
PEOPLE FORGET.
>> OKAY.
WELL WHAT ABOUT TIME WHEN
PEOPLE ORGANIZED AGAINST
UNIVERSAL
PASS, AND WE GOT TO HEAR THE
WORST TAKES AT YALE SINCE
I WAS DEFERRED WHEN I APPLIED
EARLY ACTION
CHASE: IHEA, IT'S BEEN FOUR
YEARS. YOU'VE GOTTA GET OVER
THAT.
>> I'M WITH YOU.
I GOT DEFERRED TOO.
THEY GAVE ME SPOT TO SOME
OLYMPIC FIGURE SKATER.
I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN I GOT HERE
I FOUGHT OFF THE OL'
INFERIORITY COMPLEX
BY JOINING THIRTY CLUBS,
NINE MAJORS AND TAKING
EIGHTEEN CLASSES.
CHASE: WHEN DID YOU SLEEP?
KYLE: IN THOSE EIGHTEEN
CLASSES.
Z TO BE FAIR,
MY PROFESSORS HAD VERY SOOTHING
VOICES
MACRINA: ALSO, IHEA,
WHY ARE YOU SO PESSIMISTIC
ABOUT YALE WHEN IT'S THE PLACE
THAT
CULTIVATED OUR TALENTS?
DO YOU KNOW HOW GOOD I'VE
GOTTEN AT BORROWING THINGS?
BORROWING MUGS FROM THE PIERSON
DINING HALL, BORROWING SUSHI
FROM THE BOW WOW.
BORROWING
PORTRAITS FROM THE YALE CENTER
FOR BRITISH ART
KYLE: MACRINA, WHAT?
WHAT WAS THAT LAST ONE THERE.
>> I GUESS YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY STARTED
MAKING ART AT YALE
CHASE: IHEA, I DIDN'T KNOW YOU
DID ART.
IHEA: YEP. I'M THE JACKSON
POLLOCK OF STREET ART. MY
CANVAS? UNSUSPECTING YALIES OUT
TO GET A LATE-NIGHT GHEAV
SANDWICH.
MACRINA: ARE YOU  THE
PAINTBALLER?
IHEA: NO
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YALE ALSO BROADENED MY
WORLDVIEW. LIKE WHERE ELSE
CAN YOU LEARN ABOUT CHINA'S
GEOPOLITICAL ROLE IN THE WORLD
AND ABOUT AFROFUTURISM,
ALL FROM DIFFERENT WHITE MEN?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> EXACTLY.
NOW WE JUST WANTED
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO REMEMBER
ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE LOST.
CHASE: DURFEES.
THE TACO BELL CANTINA.
IHEA: THOSE EVANGELICALS
THAT USED TO BE ALL OVER
CAMPUS.
CHASE: THAT FLAGPOLE THAT
WAS ON CROSS CAMPUS
%
FOR THREE WEEKS.
IHEA: JOJO'S.
KYLE: MY CULTURAL HOUSE!
CHASE: YOUR CULTURAL HOUSE?
KYLE: YOU KNOW SIGEP,
NOW EDON!
IHEA: OH, WORD.
WORD.
MACRINA: I GET IT, YOU GUYS,
SO MUCH HAS CHANGED DURING OUR
TIME AT YALE. COMING BACK TO
CAMPUS THIS YEAR FELT LIKE WHAT
I IMAGINE THE CLASS OF 1968
FEELS WHEN THEY RETURN FOR
REUNIONS.
LIKE WHOA, WOMEN!
>> IT'S CRAZY.
ONE SECOND WE'RE
SOPHOMORES, AND THE NEXT WE'RE
SENIORS?
MACRINA: YEA, LIKE, WHO ARE
THESE KIDS I HAVE TO BABYSIT?
IHEA: YEA, WHO ARE THESE KIDS I
HAVE TO BABYSIT?
KYLE AND CHASE: GUYS, YOU'RE
FROCOS.
FROCO!
CHASE: THAT'S LITERALLY YOUR
JOB.
>> ANYWAYS, NOW WE WOULD LIKE
TO SHOUT OUT SOME SPECIAL
PEOPLE WHO SHOWED UP FOR US
TODAY.
CHASE: THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
HATERS. YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE,
AND WE WOULDN'T BE HERE WITHOUT
YOU.
MACRINA: CAN WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE
OUR INCREDIBLE CLASS DAY
SPEAKER, MS. RESHMA SAUJANI,
THE FOUNDER OF GIRLS WHO CODE?
[  CHEERS ]
[
KYLE: I DO WANNA PITCH YOU MY
NON-PROFIT IDEA, MS. SAUJANI.
JUST
SPITBALLING HERE,
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
MULTIPLY YOUR NUMBERS, MAYBE.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL ABOUT
BOYS WHO CODE?
CHASE: THAT'S LITERALLY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE NEED.
MACRINA: KYLE, THAT'S JUST
THE YALE COMPUTER SCIENCE
DEPARTMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
FINE FINE FINE.
HERE'S ONE MORE
NEVER-BEFORE-USED ORIGINAL
THOUGHT TO SEND YOU ALL HOME
WITH.
MACRINA: WHERE ARE YOU GOING
WITH THIS?  MY STOMACH IS
RUMBLING.
>> THERE'S THIS THING THAT
LOOKS LIKE A RABBIT AND IT
SOMETIMES ALSO LOOKS LIKE A
DUCK.
>> WHERE ARE YOU GOING WITH
THIS NOW, KYLE?
MY STOMACH IS RUMBLING.
IHEA: OH I GET IT.
YOU LOOK AT THIS PLACE
FROM ONE ANGLE, IT'S AN UGLY
DUCKLING, OUR TRYING TIMES,
OUR LATE NIGHTS CRYING IN THE
BASEMENT OF BINGHAM.
KYLE: BUT LOOK AT IT FROM
ANOTHER, IT'S A LUCKY RABBIT'S
FOOT, A PLACE FULL OF
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
MAKE
MEMORIES AND FRIENDS
WE CAN CALL ON LONG
AFTER THOSE NIGHTS CRYING
IN THE BASEMENT OF BINGHAM.
MACRINA: GUYS DID WE JUST
LEARN PERSPECTIVE?
CHASE: ALL I LEARNED IS THE
NEXT TIME I PASS A
FAMILIAR-LOOKING SOUTH ASIAN
WOMAN OUTSIDE MY RESIDENTIAL
COLLEGE BUT DON'T SAY ANYTHING
BECAUSE I DON'T WANNA SEEM
RACIST I AM GOING TO REGRET IT
BECAUSE IT IS
DEFINITELY MINDY KALING.
KYLE: RIGHT. WELL, THERE'S
STILL
SO MUCH MORE I WANT TO SAY
ABOUT
THIS PLACE.
NO, NO, NO.
>> WHY DON'T WE SUMMIT UP?
ALL: YALE COMPLICATED, BRIGHT
COLLEGE YEARS.
BYE-BYE MARVIN CHUN.
“HANDSOME” DAN.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING THIS
WEEKEND?
YOUR MOM!
WHY DO WE PAY FOR LAUNDRY.
NEVER STOP COMPLAINING.
THANK YOU YALE.
[  CHEERS ]
>> THAT WAS GREAT.
I WAS GETTING TIRED OF THE
DUCK/RABBIT DEMO TOO.
GABRIEL KLAPHOLZ, WILL YOU
PLEASE COME UP TO THE STAGE?
THE ARTHUR TWINING HADLEY
PRIZE,
WHICH HONORS THE MEMORY
OF THE MAN WHO SERVED AS
PRESIDENT OF YALE FROM
1899 TO 1921, IS AWARDED
ANNUALLY TO THE SENIOR IN
YALE COLLEGE MAJORING IN THE
SOCIAL SCIENCES WHO RANKS
HIGHEST IN SCHOLARSHIP.
THIS YEAR, THE PRIZE IS
AWARDED TO GABRIEL KLAPHOLZ
OF BRANFORD COLLEGE.
GABRIEL KLAPHOLZ
GRADUATES SUMMA CUM LAUDE WITH
MAJORS IN HISTORY AND IN GLOBAL
AFFAIRS, AND WITH DISTINCTION
IN BOTH OF HIS MAJORS.
HE HAS ALSO COMPLETED THE
MULTIDISCIPLINARY ACADEMIC
PROGRAM IN HUMAN RIGHTS
STUDIES.
AS A FIRST-YEAR STUDENT,
HE WAS AWARDED THE
E. FRANCIS RIGGS
MEMORIAL PRIZE
FOR DISTINCTION IN DIRECTED
STUDIES. HE WAS ELECTED TO
PHI BETA KAPPA IN THE FIRST
ELECTION IN THE FALL OF HIS
JUNIOR YEAR, AND HE IS A 2022
RECIPIENT OF A FOX
INTERNATIONAL
FELLOWSHIP.
BEYOND THE CLASSROOM, GABRIEL'S
IMPACT ON CAMPUS HAS BEEN
WIDELY FELT, FROM HIS WORK AS
OPINION EDITOR FOR THE YALE
DAILY NEWS AND AS A
STAFF WRITER FOR THE YALE
POLITIC, TO HIS SERVICE
AS THE CO-PRESIDENT OF THE
YALE UNDERGRADUATE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION. AN AWARDEE
OF THE LIMON SUMMER FELLOWSHIP
FROM THE YALE LAW SCHOOL,
AND AN EDITORIAL INTERN
AT THE YALE LAW JOURNAL,
GABRIEL HAS SHOWN A
DEDICATION TO WORKING
FOR EQUITY AND JUSTICE
THAT WILL SURELY HAVE
AN IMPACT WELL BEYOND
YALE AS WELL.
IN RECOGNITION OF HIS
EXCEPTIONAL RECORD AND
PROMISE OF FUTURE SUCCESS,
YALE COLLEGE PROUDLY CONFERS
THE ARTHUR TWINING HADLEY HIGH
SCHOLARSHIP PRIZE
THIS YEAR UPON
GABRIEL KLAPHOLZ.
[  CHEERS ]
MATTHEW KING AND SARAH ZHAO,
WILL YOU PLEASE COME UP
TO THE STAGE?
THE RUSSELL HENRY CHITTENDEN
PRIZE IS AWARDED ANNUALLY FOR
THE SENIOR MAJORING IN THE
NATURAL SCIENCES OR IN
MATHEMATICS WHO RANKS
HIGHEST IN SCHOLARSHIP.
THIS YEAR'S PRIZE IS
AWARDED JOINTLY TO
MATTHEW JOHN KING OF
EZRA STILES COLLEGE AND
SARAH MING-XIN ZHAO
OF BERKELEY COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MATTHEW KING,
A DOUBLE-MAJOR IN PHYSICS
INTENSIVE AND MATHEMATICS
INTENSIVE, GRADUATES
SUMMA CUM LAUDE
WITH DISTINCTION
IN BOTH MAJORS.
IN HIS JUNIOR YEAR,
HE WAS ELECTED TO
PHI BETA KAPPA AND
SIGMA PI SIGMA.
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM,
MATT DEVOTES MUCH OF HIS
TIME TO CREATIVE
EXPRESSION AND
TEACHING OTHERS:
HE HAS SERVED AS AN
UNDERGRADUATE
LEARNING ASSISTANT IN THE
MATHEMATICS DEPARTMENT,
A COURSE-BASED PEER TUTOR
IN THE PHYSICS DEPARTMENT,
AND AN INSTRUCTOR WITH
YALE SPLASH. HE IS AN EAGLE
SCOUT, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE YALE GUILD OF
BOOKMAKERS,
AND AN ACCOMPLISHED
WRITER AND MUSICIAN.
AN ASPIRING PROFESSOR,
MATT HAS SPENT THE LAST TWO
SUMMERS RESEARCHING PARTICLE
PHYSICS AT THE FERMILAB IN
ILLINOIS. HE WILL BEGIN A PH.D.
IN PARTICLE PHYSICS AT YALE IN
THE FALL AND HAS BEEN AWARDED
A FELLOWSHIP BY THE NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION'S GRADUATE
RESEARCH FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM.
FOR HIS EXCEPTIONAL SCHOLARSHIP
AND HIS FUTURE PROMISE IN HIS
FIELD, YALE COLLEGE IS
PROUD TO CONFER THE RUSSELL
HENRY CHITTENDEN PRIZE UPON
MATTHEW JOHN KING.
[  CHEERS ]
SARAH ZHAO, A DOUBLE MAJOR
IN MATHEMATICS AND STATISTICS
AND DATA SCIENCE, WHILE ALSO
COMPLETING A SIMULTANEOUS
MASTER'S DEGREE IN STATISTICS
AND DATA SCIENCE, GRADUATES
SUMMA CUM LAUDE AND WITH
DISTINCTION IN BOTH MAJORS.
INDUCTED INTO PHI BETA KAPPA IN
HER JUNIOR YEAR, SHE IS A 2022
CHURCHILL SCHOLAR AND WINNER OF
THE BISHOP BERKELEY PRIZE GIVEN
TO THE BERKELEY COLLEGE SENIOR
WHO HAS “BEST DISCOVERED THE
INTELLECTUAL POTENTIALITIES
OF A UNIVERSITY.”
SHE ALSO WAS NAMED A
BARRY M. GOLDWATER SCHOLAR
IN 2021.
SARAH HAS CONDUCTED RESEARCH
IN A VARIETY OF AREAS
INCLUDING THEORETICAL
STATISTICS, DIFFUSION
GEOMETRY AND TOPOLOGY, AND
QUANTUM COMPUTING.
BEYOND THE CLASSROOM,
SARAH HAS SERVED AS
CO-PRESIDENT OF YALE'S
PHI BETA KAPPA CHAPTER,
A BOARD MEMBER OF THE YALE
EDUCATION TUTORING
INITIATIVE, AND AN
UNDERGRADUATE
LEARNING ASSISTANT FOR THE
MATHEMATICS AND STATISTICS
AND DATA SCIENCE DEPARTMENTS.
NEXT YEAR, SHE WILL USE HER
CHURCHILL SCHOLARSHIP TO
PURSUE AN M.PHIL. DEGREE IN
ADVANCED COMPUTER SCIENCE
WITH A FOCUS ON MACHINE
LEARNING
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CAMBRIDGE.
FOR HER EXCEPTIONAL SCHOLARSHIP
AND HER FUTURE PROMISE IN HER
FIELD, YALE COLLEGE IS PROUD
TO CONFER THE RUSSELL HENRY
CHITTENDEN PRIZE UPON
SARAH MING-XIN ZHAO.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
CHIA AMISOLA
AND ALEX WHITTINGTON,
WILL YOU PLEASE COME UP
TO THE STAGE?
THE LOUIS SUDLER PRIZES FOR
EXCELLENCE IN THE PERFORMING
AND CREATIVE ARTS ARE AWARDED
TO TWO OUTSTANDING SENIORS,
CHIA AMISOLA
OF SAYBROOK COLLEGE
AND ALEX WHITTINGTON
OF PIERSON COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHIA AMISOLA, A COMPUTING
AND ARTS MAJOR ON THE VISUAL
ART TRACK, GRADUATES CUM
LAUDE AND WITH DISTINCTION.
AN ARTIST WHO USES
TECHNOLOGY TO QUESTION AND
CONTEMPLATE THE NATURE
OF THE VIRTUAL WORLD,
CHIA MAKES WORK THAT TREATS
DIGITAL SPACE LIKE A TACTILE
MEDIUM, SHAPING IT INTO
SOMETHING AT ONCE FOREIGN
AND FAMILIAR, AND THAT
REQUIRES AUDIENCES,
PARTICULARLY YOUNG ONES, TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR COMPLEX
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
ONLINE LIVES.
USING COMPUTER APPLICATIONS,
GAMES WITHIN GAMES, AND
SOCIAL WORLDS MAPPED ONTO
REAL GEOGRAPHY, CHIA EXPOSES
THE PERVASIVE, POWERFUL
FORCES OF THE DIGITAL
WORLD━BOTH POSITIVE AND
NEGATIVE━AND HOW THEY HAVE
BECOME SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT, MOST DEEPLY FELT
ASPECTS OF OUR LIVES.
MUCH OF THIS WORK HAS
ALREADY MADE AN IMPACT
AROUND THE WORLD THROUGH
CHIA'S NON-PROFIT, DEVELOPH.
FOR THEIR EXCEPTIONAL TALENT
AND VISION, PRESENT AND FUTURE,
YALE COLLEGE IS PROUD TO
AWARD THE LOUIS SUDLER PRIZE
FOR EXCELLENCE IN THE CREATIVE
AND PERFORMING ARTS
TO CHIARA AMISOLA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALEX WHITTINGTON,
A MUSIC MAJOR GRADUATING CUM
LAUDE AND WITH DISTINCTION,
IS A MULTI-DIMENSIONAL
PERFORMER WHOSE WORK IN THE
THEATER AND CONCERT HALL
BRINGS NEW PERSPECTIVES TO
WORKS THAT CROSS CULTURAL
AND SOCIAL BOUNDARIES.
ALEX IS A SINGER, CONDUCTOR,
DIRECTOR, AND CHOREOGRAPHER
WHO BREATHES LIFE INTO MUSIC
OLD AND NEW, DRAWING ON THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN MARGINALIZED
SPACES OF PUERTO RICAN, QUEER
IDENTITY AS WELL AS A SOLID
GROUNDING IN RECEIVED
TRADITIONS OF MUSIC AS ART.
WITH A RANGE THAT SPANS GREEK
TRAGEDY TO BROADWAY,
ALEX HAS CREATED
PERFORMANCES THAT ARE AS
TECHNOLOGICALLY ACCOMPLISHED
AS THEY ARE ARTISTICALLY
MOTIVATED, DRAWING EQUALLY
ON MULTI-DISCIPLINARY
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE AND
PERSONAL JOURNEY AND
DEMONSTRATING A SERIOUS
BELIEF IN THE RELEVANCE AND
IMPORTANCE OF THE PERFORMING
ARTS IN TODAY'S SOCIETY.
FOR THEIR EXTRAORDINARY
ARTISTIC TALENTS, AND IN
ANTICIPATION OF THEIR
CREATIVE WORK AHEAD, YALE
COLLEGE IS PROUD TO AWARD
THE LOUIS SUDLER PRIZE FOR
EXCELLENCE IN THE PERFORMING
ARTS TO ALEX WHITTINGTON.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
MARY ELIZABETH ORSAK,
WILL YOU PLEASE COME
UP TO THE STAGE?
THE ALPHEUS HENRY SNOW PRIZE
IS AWARDED TO THAT
“SENIOR WHO, THROUGH THE
COMBINATION OF INTELLECTUAL
ACHIEVEMENT, CHARACTER, AND
PERSONALITY, SHALL BE
ADJUDGED BY THE FACULTY
TO HAVE DONE THE MOST FOR
YALE BY INSPIRING IN
HIS OR HER CLASSMATES AN
ADMIRATION AND LOVE
FOR THE BEST TRADITIONS
OF HIGH SCHOLARSHIP.”
THIS YEAR, BOTH THE WARREN
AND THE SNOW PRIZE
ARE AWARDED TO
MARY ELIZABETH ORSAK
OF PIERSON COLLEGE.
[  CHEERS ]
MARY ELIZABETH ORSAK
GRADUATES SUMMA CUM LAUDE,
WITH DISTINCTION IN HER
MAJOR, RUSSIAN.
SHE WAS ELECTED TO PHI BETA
KAPPA AFTER JUST FOUR TERMS
OF ENROLLMENT.
MARY HAS SERVED IN THREE
SEPARATE RESEARCH
ASSISTANTSHIPS RANGING
WIDELY IN FORM AND FOCUS,
FROM THE ARCHIVAL STUDY OF
MATERIALS IN THE GUGGENHEIM
MUSEUM AND THE MUSEUM OF
MODERN ART COLLECTIONS,
TO THE PRODUCTION OF WEB
CONTENT AND GRAPHICS ON
RUSSIAN HACKERS, TO THE
PLANNING OF A CONFERENCE
ON THE USE OF BODIES AS A
FORM OF PROTEST IN RUSSIAN
AND EASTERN EUROPEAN
PERFORMANCE ART.
SHE HAS ALSO WORKED AS A
LANGUAGE TUTOR IN BOTH
RUSSIAN AND CZECH IN THE
YALE CENTER FOR LANGUAGE
STUDY, AS AN ART AND
ARCHITECTURE EDITORIAL
AND MARKETING INTERN FOR
YALE UNIVERSITY PRESS,
AND AS A MANAGING AND
DESIGN EDITOR FOR THE
YALE REVIEW OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDIES.
MARY HAS LONG SERVED THE
COMMUNITY AS A VOLUNTEER,
BOTH AT THE UNIVERSITY AND
ACROSS THE CITY OF NEW HAVEN.
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNITY POLICING AND
DIRECTOR AT WALDEN PEER
COUNSELING, WHERE SHE
PROVIDED ANONYMOUS,
NON-DIRECTIVE PEER
GUIDANCE TO OTHER STUDENTS.
SHE ALSO SERVED FOR TWO YEARS
AS CURRICULUM DIRECTOR FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH EDUCATORS,
PLANNING AND OFFERING CLASSES
ON HEALTH, WELLNESS, AND
SEXUALITY TO PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN THE CITY.
SHE HAS ALSO CONTINUED TO
BE INVOLVED IN HER HOMETOWN
OF DALLAS, WHERE SHE FOUNDED
AND SERVES AS PRESIDENT OF A
NONPROFIT, STORY POWER INC.,
WHICH IS DEDICATED TO
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
YOUNG GIRLS THROUGH
THE DONATION OF BOOKS ABOUT
AND BY INSPIRING WOMEN.
NEXT YEAR, MARY WILL PURSUE
A MASTER OF PHILOSOPHY IN
RUSSIAN AND EAST EUROPEAN
STUDIES AT OXFORD UNIVERSITY
AS A RHODES SCHOLAR.
[  CHEERS ]
IN RECOGNITION OF HER
INTELLECTUAL ACHIEVEMENTS
AND HER EXEMPLARY CHARACTER
AS A COMMUNITY CITIZEN,
YALE COLLEGE IS PROUD
TO AWARD BOTH THE WARREN
MEMORIAL HIGH SCHOLARSHIP
PRIZE AND THE ALPHEUS
HENRY SNOW PRIZE TO
MARY ELIZABETH ORSAK.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> FOUR YEARS AGO, I CAME TO
YALE CAUTIOUSLY HOPEFUL,
BUT MORE CANDIDLY, CYNICAL.
BEFORE YALE, I HAD ATTENDED
A PRE-COLLEGE PROGRAM
THAT I WAS INITIALLY
INCREDIBLY EXCITED ABOUT.
INSTEAD, IT TURNED OUT
TO BE A COMPLETE DISASTER.
STUDENTS ASKED TO REMOVE
ME FROM PHOTOS BECAUSE MY
WHEELCHAIR “RUINED IT,”
ASKED THE BUS DRIVER TO
LEAVE WITHOUT ME BECAUSE THE
“LIFT TOOK TOO LONG,” AND
THE LIST GOES ON. PERHAPS
UNSURPRISINGLY, THE
EXPERIENCE JADED ME:
IT CONVINCED ME THAT
CONTRARY TO WHAT I HOPED,
COLLEGE WOULD BE A PLACE
WHERE I WOULD BE DEFINED
BY MY DISABILITY AND THAT
THAT SURFACE-LEVEL
UNDERSTANDING WOULD LEAD TO
PERPETUAL EXCLUSION.
I WAS READY TO REPEAT
THE SUMMER OF 2017
FOR FOUR MORE YEARS.
YALE POWERFULLY━AND
UNEXPECTEDLY━RESTORED
THE HOPE THAT I HAD LOST
BY CONSISTENTLY COUNTERING
THAT NARRATIVE THROUGH THIS
COMMUNITY'S UNCONDITIONAL
INTEGRITY AND CULTURE OF
ACCEPTANCE.
YALE IS A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN MEANINGFULLY
DREAM TOWARDS A FUTURE
THAT THEY CREATE.
FOR EVERY PERSON HERE,
THAT DREAM MEANS SOMETHING
UNIQUELY BEAUTIFUL.
HOW DID I BECOME SO CONVINCED
OF THIS THAT I'M SHARING
IT WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY?
IT IS THE LIVING PROOF
I HAVE THROUGH EXPERIENCING
DAILY ACTS OF COMPASSION
THAT EXTEND BEYOND WHAT
I FIND COMPREHENSIBLE
TO BE HUMBLING, HILARIOUS,
AND HEARTWARMING.
IT IS A PLACE WHERE WHEN
I'M -- PERHAPS SHAMEFULLY --
TEXTING WHILE DRIVING IN THE
DINING HALL AND SUBSEQUENTLY
DROP A PLATE, SOMEONE WILL
BE THERE TO PICK IT UP.
IT IS A PLACE
WHERE GROUPS OF STUDENTS
WILL FIGHT TO HAVE AN
ELEVATOR PUT IN A
SEVERAL-HUNDRED-YEAR-OLD
BUILDING WITHOUT ME EVEN
KNOWING JUST BECAUSE THEY
FEEL IT IS RIGHT.
IT IS A PLACE WHERE,
DURING SPRING FLING,
PEOPLE WILL STOP TO FIX MY
JOYSTICK
GOT TRAMPLED WHILE STRANGERS
WILL PUSH ME OUT OF DIRT.
IT IS ALSO A PLACE WHERE
STRANGERS
WILL RUN INTO ONCOMING TRAFFIC
WHEN THEY NOTICE A WATER BOTTLE
FELL FROM MY LAP FROM A BLOCK
AWAY.
IT IS A PLACE WHERE PROFESSORS
WILL MAKE SURE I'M TAKEN CARE
OF IN THEIR EMERGENCY ROOM
WHILE ALSO MAKING SURE THAT I'M
CHALLENGED IN THEIR CLASSROOM
THE NEXT DAY.
IT IS A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE WILL FORM A
CIRCLE AROUND MY WHEELCHAIR
AT WOADS SO NO ONE HITS IT.
AND IT IS A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
WILL TAKE ON ALL THE RAIN
TO HOLD AN UMBRELLA OVER ME
SO THAT MY WHEELCHAIR DOESN'T
GET WET.
ULTIMATELY, IT IS A PLACE WHERE
THINGS THAT I VIEWED AS
IMPOSSIBLE
ARE MADE EFFORTLESSLY POSSIBLE.
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE THAT
PERHAPS MARKS MY MOST
TRANSFORMATIVE MOMENT HERE.
I WAS A FIRST-YEAR,
AND A SENIOR HAD WRITTEN
A NEWS PIECE THAT━THOUGH
COMPLETELY WELL INTENTIONED━
MADE MY EXPERIENCE AS A
DISABLED STUDENT LOOK QUITE
BLEAK. I ULTIMATELY FELT THAT
THE PORTRAYAL PAINTED A PART,
BUT NOT A WHOLE PICTURE,
OF MY EXPERIENCE.
SO, I WROTE AN ARTICLE IN
RESPONSE TO FILL IN THOSE
MISSING PIECES OF
LIGHT AND JOY.
I WAS TERRIFIED.
IT WAS THE BEST DECISION
I HAVE MADE AT YALE━
ALL BECAUSE OF THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING ME TODAY.
I MADE ONE OF MY BEST
FRIENDS; SHE HAD LIVED
ON MY FLOOR BUT WE HAD NOT
REALLY CONNECTED UNTIL SHE
REACHED OUT TO GET A MEAL
AFTER SEEING THE PIECE.
PEOPLE WHO I BARELY SPOKE
TO AT THE TIME RESHARED THE
ARTICLE ON
FACEBOOK SO MANY TIMES THAT
IT SHOCKINGLY WENT TO NUMBER
ONE, SHOWING ME THAT PEOPLE
WERE WILLING TO LISTEN.
STILL, OTHERS MESSAGED ME EVERY
SINGLE DAY ASKING IF I WAS
OKAY AND REMINDING ME THAT
IT WOULD BE OKAY.
PEOPLE WERE RADICALLY AND
SINCERELY OPEN TO MAKING
SPACE FOR DIFFERENCE IN
PERSPECTIVE AND EXPERIENCE.
AND I NEVER HAD TO WORRY
ABOUT OPENING A DOOR AGAIN!
THE EXPERIENCE SHOWED ME THAT
WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE WAS
LARGELY MY FAULT; I AVOIDED
BEING VULNERABLE OUT OF FEAR,
AND I MISSED OUT AS A RESULT.
THIS EXPERIENCE IS A TESTAMENT
TO VULNERABILITY BEING
SUPPORTED AND EVEN REWARDED
HERE. IT IS A TESTAMENT TO
THIS COMMUNITY CHAMPIONING
THOSE WHO CREATE THEIR OWN
IDENTITY. IT IS A TESTAMENT
TO YALE BEING A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE WHO YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WERE YOUR ALLIES WILL RALLY
BEHIND YOU THROUGH BOTH MOMENTS
OF TREMENDOUS ADVERSITY AND
VICTORY.
IT IS A TESTAMENT TO THE
COMMUNITY'S READINESS TO
DEFINE YALE━AND THE WORLD━BY
INCLUSION AND BETTERMENT.
I HOPE THIS LIST OF
ANECDOTES SHOW THAT YALE
IS A PLACE OF REMARKABLE
PASSION: FOR PEOPLE, FOR
EMPATHY, FOR HUMILITY,
AND FOR DOING THE MOST
GOOD IN THE SITUATIONS WE
FIND OURSELVES IN.
OUR COMMUNITY IS ONE MARKED
BY AN ARDENTLY SELFLESS
COMMITMENT TO CARING
FOR OTHERS.
MY TIME HERE HAS SHOWN ME TWO
THINGS.
AT YALE WHEN WE LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER, WE GROW SMARTER.
WHEN WE LEAN ON EACH OTHER, WE
GROW STRONGER.
I ONCE READ THAT RAY CHARLES'S
MOTHER SAID TO HIM:
“YOU MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO DO
THINGS LIKE A PERSON WHO CAN
SEE. BUT THERE ARE ALWAYS TWO
WAYS TO DO EVERYTHING.
YOU'VE JUST GOT TO FIND THE
OTHER WAY.” I WROTE IN MY
COLLEGE APPLICATION THAT
I HOPED I WOULD ACHIEVE
THAT ONE DAY, AND THE YALE
COMMUNITY HAS MADE THAT
POSSIBLE BY FINDING THAT WAY
WITH ME.
THOUGH THE MAP LOOKS
DIFFERENT FOR EVERYONE,
I THINK THAT SENTIMENT IS━
AT ITS CORE━THE DEFINITION
OF A YALE EXPERIENCE.
SO, CONGRATULATIONS,
AND PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THANK YOU TO THE
CLASS OF 2022.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
VICTORIA: GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE.  I'M VICTORIA WINTE━-
CHRISTINE: I'M CHRISTINE
HOCHEN━
STEFY: AND I'M STEFY GRAU, AND
WE'RE ALL MEMBERS OF THE 2022
CLASS DAY COMMITTEE.
[  CHEERS ]
CHRISTINE: AND AS MEMBERS
OF THE CLASS DAY COMMITTEE,
WE'RE UP HERE TO HELP
EXPLAIN SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'VE DONE TO HELP
KEEP UP THE YALE CLASS
DAY TRADITIONS,
AS WE CELEBRATE THE
GRADUATION OF OUR
CLASS OF 2022!
VICTORIA: AS A MEMBER OF THE
2022 CLASS DAY COMMITTEE,
I COORDINATED THIS
YEAR'S CLASS HISTORY.
THE CLASS HISTORY
HAS TAKEN MANY FORMS
OVER THE YEARS TO
TELL THE STORY OF OUR
TIME AT YALE FROM LIVE
SKITS, TO HIGHLY PRODUCED
SCRIPTED MOVIES AND EVEN
NOSTALGIC SLIDESHOWS.
AS AN HOMAGE TO PAST
CLASS HISTORIES,
WHILE STILL INCORPORATING
STUDENT INPUT,
THIS YEAR'S VIDEO WILL BE A
HYBRID BETWEEN SCRIPTED
AND STUDENT-SUBMITTED WORKS.
AFTER THE UNVEILING OF OUR
CLASS HISTORY, WILL BE THE
SINGING OF
“BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS,”
A SONG WRITTEN IN 1881
BY HENRY DURAND
WHICH HAS BEEN THE UNOFFICIAL
ALMA MATER OF YALE SINCE.
SUNG AT REUNIONS, FOOTBALL
GAMES, AND CLASS DAY,
IT REMAINS A SYMBOL OF YALE'S
TRADITIONS AND LONG, LONG
HISTORY. ON THE LAST LINES OF
THE SONG, WE RAISE
HANDKERCHIEFS.
IF YOU LOST YOURS FROM
FIRST YEAR OR NEVER GOT ONE
LIKE ME, THE
YALE ALUMNI ASSOCIATION HAS
GENEROUSLY PROVIDED NEW ONES.
WE'LL WAVE THEM ALONG, AS YEARS
OF GRADUATING CLASSES HAVE DONE
BEFORE US, SINGING
“FOR GOD, FOR COUNTRY,
AND FOR YALE.”
CHRISTINE: THE THREE
INCREDIBLE STUDENT SPEECHES
YOU'VE JUST HEARD THIS
AFTERNOON BY MEMBERS OF OUR
CLASS ARE ALSO A TRADITION AT
YALE: LEGACIES OF THE DAYS
WHEN YALIES DELIVERED FORMAL
ACADEMIC SPEECHES DURING THIS
CEREMONY. EACH YEAR, SPEAKERS
AUDITION BEFORE THE
CLASS DAY SPEAKER
SUBCOMMITTEE, WHICH THIS
YEAR INCLUDED MYSELF,
JAY, AND YOUSRA, WHO
YOU HEARD FROM EARLIER.
THE SPEECHES ARE SELECTED
TO HIGHLIGHT THE
BEAUTIFUL SPECTRUM
OF EXPERIENCE HERE AT
YALE. IT WAS AN HONOR TO
LISTEN TO SO MANY INDIVIDUAL
STORIES, ALL STRAIGHT
FROM THE HEART.
WE HOPED YOU ENJOYED THE
VULNERABILITY, CANDOR,
EMOTION━AND HUMOR━THAT
CHARLOTTE, CHASE, IHEA,
MACRINA, KYLE,
AND ARYA BROUGHT TO
THEIR REFLECTIONS OF YALE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
STEFY: ANOTHER TRADITION
IS THE CREATION OF THE 2022
CLASS DAY ANTHOLOGY, WHICH I
HELPED OUR CLASS TO PUT
TOGETHER
AND EDIT AS A MEMBER OF OUR
CLASZ DAY COMMITTEE.
YOU CAN FIND A COPY OF IT ALSO
INCLUDED
IN YOUR CLASS DAY BAGS.
THE CLASS DAY ANTHOLOGY IS A
BOOKLET OF REFLECTIONS,
WORKS OF ART, AND POETRY
THAT CAPTURE OUR BEAUTIFUL
SHARED
YALE EXPERIENCE. WE SELECTED
PIECES THAT WE FOUND TO BE
EXCEPTIONALLY REPRESENTATIVE OF
OUR TIMES HERE AS STUDENTS━BOTH
THE HAPPY EXPERIENCES AND THE
MORE CHALLENGING ONES. WE WENT
INTO THIS PROJECT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS NO
SUCH THING AS A SINGULAR YALE
EXPERIENCE. WE PUT TOGETHER
THIS COLLECTION, WHICH
ENCOMPASSES A VARIETY OF
PERSPECTIVES, AND WE HOPE
YOU'LL TAKE THE TIME TO READ
THROUGH IT AND REFLECT ON
YOUR OWN FOUR YEARS HERE.
OR MORE.
YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISED AT THE
THEMES THAT TIE US TOGETHER.
CHRISTINE: YOU'LL ALSO FIND A
CLAY PIPE IN YOUR CLASS DAY
GIFT
BAG, CALLED THE CHURCHWARDEN
PIPE, IN ADDITION TO SOME
BUBBLES. WHEN THIS TRADITION
STARTED BACK IN 1869,
GRADUATING SENIORS WOULD
SIT IN A CIRCLE,
SMOKING TOBACCO FROM THESE
PIPES.
IT'S DEFINITELY A DIFFERENT
VIBE TODAY━WE HAVE ON FUNKY
HATS, AND WE BLOW BUBBLES━BUT
THIS TRADITION OF THE
CHURCHWARDEN PIPE
STILL ENDURES OVER
150 YEARS LATER.
VICTORIA: ANOTHER TRADITION
THAT BEGAN IN 1851 IS
THE LAYING OF AN IVY PLANT
SOMEWHERE ON YALE'S CAMPUS,
SYMBOLIZING THE ENDURING
NATURE OF THE FRIENDSHIPS
MADE IN THE PAST FOUR YEARS.
THIS YEAR, OUR CLASS IVY
WILL BE PLACED RIGHT INSIDE
OF PHELPS GATE,
PLANTED BENEATH A STONE
ON THE WALL WHERE WITH
OUR YEAR ‘2022' WILL BE
ENGRAVED.
FUTURE GENERATIONS
WILL COME THROUGH
OLD CAMPUS AND SEE OUR
IVY AND ENGRAVED STONE AS
SYMBOLS OF THE ENDURING
RESILIENCE AND STRENGTH OUR
CLASS FOUND HERE.
CHRISTINE: A LOT OF TIME HAS
PASSED. AND YALE NO LONGER
LOOKS THE WAY IT ONCE DID.
THE YALIES OF TODAY DON'T
LOOK LIKE THE YALIES OF THE
1800'S, BUT THE PLANTING
OF THE IVY AND THE
CHURCHWARDEN PIPE ARE
TWO TRADITIONS THAT UNITE
GENERATIONS OF YALE
GRADUATES.
STEFY: FINALLY, LOOKING
AHEAD TO TOMORROW MORNING'S
COMMENCEMENT PROCESSION, AS
TRADITION, THE RECIPIENTS OF
THE
FIVE ACADEMIC PRIZES THAT WERE
JUST AWARDED BY DEAN CHUN WILL
CARRY AN OFFICIAL FLAG OR
BANNER.
THE WINNERS OF THE WARREN
MEMORIAL PRIZE,
RUSSELL HENRY CHITTENDEN
PRIZE, ARTHUR TWINING
HADLEY PRIZE, SUDLER
PRIZE, AND ALPHEUS
HENRY SNOW PRIZE
CARRY THE AMERICAN FLAG,
CONNECTICUT FLAG,
YALE COLLEGE BANNER,
PRESIDENT'S BANNER,
AND YALE UNIVERSITY
BANNER, RESPECTIVELY.
THESE PARTS OF CLASS DAY,
SOME MORE SILLY AND SOME
MORE SERIOUS, ALL LINK
OUR CLASS OF 2022 TO THE
GENERATIONS OF YALIES
THAT CAME BEFORE, AS WE MOVE
FROM BEING UNDERGRADUATES
TO ALUMNI OF YALE.
UNIVERSITY
CHRISTINE, VICTORIA,
AND I, ALONG WITH YOUSRA
AND JAY, FEEL SO LUCKY
AND HONORED
TO HAVE HELPED OUR CLASS
CARRY ON THESE TRADITIONS.
VICTORIA: DEFINITELY.
CONGRATULATIONS EVERYONE!
[ APPLAUSE ]
BEFORE WE BEGIN THE CLASS
HISTORY, I HAVE ONE ORDER OF
BUSINESS: WILL THE MEMBERS OF
THE GLEE CLUB PLEASE MAKE THEIR
WAY TO THE BANDSTAND?
AND NOW, WITHOUT FURTHER ADO,
THE 2022 CLASS HISTORY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪ BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS
WITH PLEASURE RIFE ♪
♪ THE SHORTEST, GLADDEST
YEARS OF LIFE ♪
♪ HOW SWIFTLY ARE
YE GLIDING BY ♪
♪ OH, WHY DOTH TIME
SO QUICKLY FLY ♪
♪ THE SEASONS COME
THE SEASONS GO ♪
♪ THE EARTH IS GREEN
OR WHITE WITH SNOW ♪
♪ BUT TIME AND CHANGE
SHALL NAUGHT AVAIL ♪
♪ TO BREAK THE FRIENDSHIPS
FORMED AT YALE ♪
♪ IN AFTER YEARS
SHOULD TROUBLES RISE ♪
♪ TO CLOUD THE BLUE
OF SUNNY SKIES ♪
♪ HOW BRIGHT WILL SEEM
THROUGH MEM'RY'S HAZE ♪
♪ THOSE HAPPY, GOLDEN
BYGONE DAYS ♪
♪ OH, LET US STRIVE
THAT EVER WE ♪
♪ MAY LET THESE WORDS
OUR WATCH-CRY BE ♪
♪ WHERE'ER UPON
LIFE'S SEA WE SAIL ♪
♪ FOR GOD, FOR COUNTRY
AND FOR YALE ♪
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> ALL RIGHT, EVERYONE.
I'VE LOST MY VOICE FROM
SCREAMING SO MUCH WITH ALL OF
YOU TODAY.
WE JUST WANTED TO SAY A QUICK
THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL TO THE
YALE FACULTY AND STAFF WHO HAVE
MADE OUR YALE EXPERIENCES
POSSIBLE, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE PARTING WAYS WITH YALE WITH
US.
THOSE WOULD BE PEOPLE LIKE OUR
HEADS OF COLLEGES, MY OWN HEAD,
JOHN WITT AS WELL AS DEAN OF
YALE COLLEGE MARVIN CHUN.
IF YOU CAN HELP ME GIVE THEM
ALL A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH.
CLASS OF 2022, YOU ARE FREE TO
GO.
STAY HYDRATED,
AND CONGRATULATIONS CLASS OF
2022!